[Music]
so you think going to the movies by
yourself is for losers well would a
losers get to eat an entire box of Milk
Duds all by themselves and not worry
about someone else taking them no
because that's the very definition of
winning when you go see a movie by
yourself you can go whenever you want
he'll go see a matinee this is your
special day plus you're not to worry
about anyone else making you late
because you're always on time look I'm
just gonna have to head into the theater
I'll be on the left side the left side
best of all you get to see whatever you
want because this day is all about you
hey could I get one to see the most
brainless romantic comedy you have you
can sit wherever you want
you don't have to come in and ask people
to move to make room for your date
unless you get the jumbo tub oh and you
get both armrests too if you want to cry
go ahead and cry no one's gonna judge
you no one's even gonna talk to you at
all it's the whatever I'm never gonna
see these people again and if the movie
blows you can totally just walk out and
get zero are you convinced well whatever
the best part of going to the movies by
yourself is you don't need anyone else
to do it
[Music]